reactivación poderío y pertenencia tres
palabras para definir el lema de lo que
será la presidencia rotatoria del
consejo europeo que francia asumirá a
partir del primero de enero de 2022
desde el inicio el presidente manuel
micrones puso sus prioridades proyectos
para lograr una europa poderosa en el
mundo plenamente soberana
empezando por el control de las
fronteras luego hubo una europa soberana
para mí tiene el aspecto principal de
poder mantener sus fronteras bajo
control
si te hemos visto de nuevo en las
últimas semanas con la crisis que hemos
experimentado en las fronteras
orientales de europa luego pidió también
una reforma a la zona schengen
deseamos poner en marcha un proyecto
político piloto de esta zona a través de
reuniones periódicas de los ministros a
cargo de estos temas se cuestión el
mandatario propone que europa fortalezca
sus lazos con áfrica en temas de salud
clima y seguridad y
creo profundamente que el vínculo entre
nuestros dos continentes a ambos lados
del mediterráneo es el gran proyecto
político y geopolítico de la próxima
década
de diseñe macrón buscará que la unión
europea considere nuevas formas para
salir de la crisis económica causada por
la pandemia y luchará por un salario
mínimo decente y generalizado en el
bloque de los 27 regular el contenido y
los discursos de odio en las grandes
plataformas digitales será otra
prioridad
todos los días hablamos sobre temas de
antisemitismo racismo incitación al odio
y acoso en línea estrictamente hablando
no existe una regulación internacional
sobre este tema con asociación para
ayudar a combatir el cambio climático
propondrá un plan de crecimiento que
respeten las ambiciones medioambientales
de la unión europea y detener
importaciones de productos que
contribuyan a la estación